morgan wallen is speaking out in his
first interview since he was caught on
camera using the n-word
and other vulgar language back in
february major fallout ensued just hours
after the incident
the country singer was suspended from
his label big loud records
and dropped by his booking agency wme
several radio stations and streaming
platforms removed morgan's music from
their playlists
and additionally he was deemed
ineligible for the upcoming academy of
country music awards that took place in
april
and joining michael strahan on good
morning america for an in-depth
conversation
the singer reflected on the incident
admitting uh he was
ignorant and drunk at the time and he
insisted
it isn't a slur he uses frequently
i had some some of my you know long time
friends in town
you know we'd kind of just been partying
all weekend and we figured we'd just
go hard for the two or three days that
they were there how did this happen out
of nowhere
you just refer to someone with a racial
slur
no i i don't think it was just it just
happened you know i was around some of
my friends
and and you know we just we stay we
stayed dumb stuff together it was
in our minds it's playful you know i
don't i don't know if that's that sounds
ignorant but that's really where it came
from
and and it's and it's wrong and had
there been no video of the incident we
obviously wouldn't be
sitting here right now this is not the
first time you said the word this is the
word that you use frequently
amongst your friends i wouldn't say
frequently no no not not frequently it
was just around this certain group of
friends i would say
and what would they use you know it's
one of my best friends he we were all
clearly drunk and i was asking his
girlfriend to
take care of him because he was drunk
and he was leaving i didn't mean it any
in any derogatory manner at all
yeah i know that's tough uh amid the
scandal morgan's second studio album
dangerous
the double album spent 10 consecutive
weeks at the top of the billboard 200
chart and his album sales increased
dramatically morgan told michael he and
his team calculated around 500
000 profits as a result of the spike in
sales
which they are going to donate that
money to black organizations including
the black music action coalition
in addition morgan revealed he checked
himself into a rehab facility to reflect
on his actions
and really quickly um the clip that
we're going to play next is michael
um he also asked morgan if he truly
understands the history of the word
and why it makes black people so upset
so we're going to show you two clips
right now
thank you i've heard some stories in the
initial conversations that i had after
that just how
just how some people are you know
treated even still today
and i'm just like i haven't seen that
with my eyes that pain or that
that insignificant feeling or whatever
it is that it makes you feel i don't
know how to put myself in their shoes
because i'm not you know
but i i do understand especially when i
when i say that i'm using it playfully
or whatever ignorantly
i understand that that must sound you
know like he doesn't he doesn't
understand
i went and checked myself into rehab and
for
for 30 days i spent some time out in san
diego california
um you know just trying to figure out
what why i'm acting this way do i have
an alcohol problem do i have a deeper
issue
hmm okay so here's a here's a comment
carl was
saying morgan was given a chance in 2020
during
uh the black lives matter movement and
he screwed up his chance out is no
excuse
i've never gotten that drunk and have
ever yelled race ever
it's in his hearts
this is how to communicate usually uh
barry's saying i fully believe that
morgan wallin is that you don't just say
for nothing uh shad spake is saying one
how long it will be before he says it
again
nelson's saying he's pretty ignorant uh
but he can change
what do you think do you think we people
are going to bring him you know going to
be okay from come back into the music
industry
well you know he's still successful
in in his music you know his fans still
support him we've seen that
you know the question for me is always
if you're not racist
you know genuinely and you use the
racial slur the question you should ask
yourself is
you know where did you get it from why
did you start using it who in your
circle is comfortable when you use it
and they do they use it too um
i just
i know that he spoken to black leaders
and i know that he went to rehab and i
do
genuinely believe he has a drinking
problem we saw how he acted
um you know during when he was supposed
to perform for snl
and he got booted because he was not
following covet protocols and we saw
those videos of him at the bar he was
kissing random girls
and you know that got him into hot water
i do believe he has a problem
um and i do appreciate that he went to
rehab to take care of himself
take care of himself as for this issue
in terms of racism you know i
i just struggle with it entirely because
i feel like
is this a teachable moment do you
understand
and empathize with the people that you
have hurt and if you have
um i think there's a chance for there to
be forgiveness and for
you know you to continue on in your
career and for people to
to embrace you again if you've learned
my
issue with this interview there's two
sides of it one is that
i still don't get the sincerity that i
need from morgan in these interviews and
then
and he gave an apology before it felt
very insincere this interview didn't
feel very sincere
and i don't know if it's just because of
the way you know it's his style of
communication i
i want to be you know a forgiving person
and try to have empathy
um but in this interview it just it just
wasn't it for me specifically
when michael strahan said do you
understand and he kind of was like well
i'm not black so i don't
you know because you're not black you
don't understand
no no no as a human being do you
understand what it means to hurt
people and that was you that hurt them
and why like we can all understand being
hurt we all
we all deal with discrimination in
different ways you don't have to be
black
to understand people's hurt so that like
even just that bothered me
he didn't really give a proper you know
explanation i mean he said that he was
drunk and this is the things that he
says to his friends
but maybe he needed to go a little
deeper into that he didn't go deeper and
on the other side of it
i really didn't like this interview from
michael strahan you know what i love
michael but i didn't like it you know i
really believe
you know as an interviewer it's
important to ask questions
to allow someone to open up and i felt
like michael strahan
you know was offended rightfully so
he had a passionate personal opinion to
this story rightfully so
but i just didn't feel like he just was
kind of getting at him in a way that
it was just a waste let morgan just put
out a pr
press release that it felt very um
unemotional and dry and i just i didn't
get what i was hoping to get out of this
morgan interview honestly
do you feel like he was too hard on
on on morgan or just already made the
decision
and this wasn't a discussion well
michael is offended you know rightfully
so he's a black man and
he hates that word and he's interviewing
someone who use it in such a derogatory
manner so i understand you know
that passion but i just felt like
he didn't necessarily facilitate an
environment for morgan to dig
deep i maybe i will maybe i wanted an
oprah interview
maybe i wanted a diane sawyer moment i
just like to get to the root of the
issue and i just felt it was very
topical for me like
racism is a deep-seated thing and they
didn't dig there it just
i didn't like it yeah yeah okay so hey
julie saying i totally agree
nicole is saying it doesn't feel sincere
it feels like he's scared for his career
i'd respect him more if he just said yes
i grew up hearing it constantly and i'm
guilty of using that word
yes yeah and and honestly like sometimes
you know people get
drunk and say offensive things and you
know and they say offensive things to
get a reaction
for drama for a laugh they want to be
cool amongst their friends and i think
if we've all you know if we all
were recorded 24 7 you know we wouldn't
be too pleased with everything that we
say especially when we're inibriated and
i totally
understand that response but at the same
time
it still feels very insincere it didn't
come from
a oh my god i am so sorry i hurt people
that's the last thing i want to do in
this life you know i just want to make
music and make people feel good
that to me is like showing some sort of
emotion
he just still seems like he's just not
there and maybe he's still on his
personal journey
you know with alcohol abuse or whatever
and he's just not there to you know to
deal with
those comments maybe he's still working
on himself i don't know but
it just i didn't get what i wanted from
this interview and i was hoping for it
because he's so
talented he really is yeah no i you know
i really actually do agree with the
sincerity just the way he's talking
about his friends and whatever like we
don't usually do this
it's like but what makes you think we
don't think you normally do this if
you're just goofing around with your
friends like i don't like that's how you
goof wrong with your friends all right i
understand you're drunk
you know at times but still
it didn't it just didn't yeah didn't uh
it didn't feel right